.
DOES DESANTIS ENTER THE PRIMARY
WITH TRUMP THAT SOUNDS VICIOUS.
GLENN YOUNGKIN IS THE GOVERNOR
OF VIRGINIA WHO JOINS ME RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT IS GOING ON DOWN THIS
FLORIDA, SOLID RED NOW, RIGHT?
>> WELL, GOOD EVENING, JESSE.
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
AND I THINK WHAT WE SAW IN
FLORIDA WAS THE RESULT OF GREAT
LEADERSHIP FROM RON DESANTIS AND
FLORIDIANS REWARDED HIM.
AND WE SAW THAT ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY WITH REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS WHO HAD DONE A GREAT
JOB LEADING OUT OF 9 PANDEMIC.
THAT'S WHAT GOVERNOR DESANTIS
DID.
I THINK THIS IS ALL ABOUT
RESULTS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY VOTERS
WANT THEIR ELECTED LEADERS TO
DELIVER RESULTS AND THEY ARE A
LOT LESS INCLINED ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT THEY ARE EITHER
REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS WHETHER
THEY'RE DELIVERING FOR HIM.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT RON DESANTIS
HAS DONE IN FLORIDA AND I THINK
WE WILL SEE IT ACROSS THE NATION
AS WE LOOK AT THESE FINAL, FINAL
RESULTS WHERE, YOU KNOW,
GOVERNOR KEMP IN GEORGIA AND
GOVERNOR DEWINE IN OHIO AND
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IN TEXAS ALL HAD
THE EXACT SAME KINDS OF STRONG
SHOWINGS BECAUSE THEY DELIVERED
RESULTS, PARTICULARLY COMING OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAW IN VIRGINIA
AS WELL, JESSE.
LAST YEAR WHEN WE BROUGHT FOLKS
TOGETHER ABOUT DELIVERING
RESULTS, I THINK THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO BRING PEOPLE TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO MAY NOT
HAVE EVER BEEN THERE BEFORE.
AND THAT'S DIRECTLY
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE MIAMI-DADE
LATINO SHOWING.
SO, THIS IS A MOMENT FOR
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS AND
PARTICULARLY RON DESANTIS TO
SHOW THAT RESULTS MATTER.
>> AND ABBOTT CRUSHED BETO AND
PUT HIM OUT OF HIS MISERY SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO WATCH HIM DANCE
AROUND ON TABLES ANYMORE.
UP AND DOWN FOR GOVERNORS,
ZELDIN CAME WITHIN INCHES, I
THOUGHT THAT WAS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT.
TUDOR WHO I KNOW YOU GAVE A VERY
NICE VEST TO UP IN MICHIGAN LOST
BY A HAIR.
THAT WAS DISAPPOINTING IT.
LOOKS LIKE KARI LAKE IS GOING TO
EKE THINGS OUT.
HOW WOULD YOU INTERPRET WHAT
HAPPENED WITH SOME OF THESE
RACES THAT DIDN'T GO, AGAIN,
PENNSYLVANIA, THAT GOVERNOR'S
RACE WAS A BLOW-OUT.
WHAT WENT WRONG THERE?
>> WELL, LET ME JUST BACK UP AND
WE STILL GOT TWO RACES WE'RE
WAITING ON AND I THINK NEVADA
AND ARIZONA LOOK LIKE THEY ARE
BREAKING THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND I THINK THAT JUST, AGAIN,
REFLECTS THE FACT THAT
ARIZONAENS WANT A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR AND NEVADA VOTERS SAID
CLEARLY THAT THEY WANT TO A
CHANGE.
AND AGAIN, RESULTS MATTER.
AND I THINK SHERIFF LOMBARDO HAS
DEMONSTRATED FOR FOLKS IN LAS
VEGAS THAT HE CAN DELIVER FOR
THEM.
AND HE IS BEING REWARDED FOR IT.
THIS IS A MOMENT WHERE FOLKS
WERE VOTING FOR PEOPLE THAT THEY
HAD TRUST IN AND A COUPLE OF
THEM CAME UP SHORT.
I REALLY WAS PULLING HARD FOR
LEE ZELDIN.
I THOUGHT HE MIGHT BECAUSE OF
THE CRIME THAT REALLY HALLS
OVERTAKEN NEW YORK REALLY SHOW
NEW YORKERS THAT REPUBLICANS
SHOULD WIN.
>> Jesse: SO, GOVERNOR, DOES RON
DESANTIS GET INTO A PRIMARY WITH
DONALD TRUMP?
>> GENTLEMAN SPECULATE WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN TERMS OF
2024.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN NOW
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GO TO WORK.
I THINK THIS IS THE BIG MESSAGE
AS WE LOOK TO THE FUTURE.
IT'S TIME TO DELIVER.
FOLKS THAT WERE REWARDED BY
STRONG SHOWINGS FROM THEIR
CONSTITUENTS NOW NEED TO GO
DELIVER FOR THEM.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE BIG
MESSAGE FOR THE REPUBLICANS IS
IT'S TIME TO DELIVER.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE GOOD ON
PROMISES MADE AND I THINK THAT
IF WE CAN DO THAT, THEN WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DELIVER ON GETTING
INFLATION DOWN AND BACK IN THE
BLUE AND MAKING SURE PARENTS ARE
AT THE HEAD OF THEIR FAMILIES
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE A GREAT
TIME FOR REPUBLICANS TO SHOW
THAT WE CAN DELIVER.
>> Jesse: ABSOLUTELY.
I'M STILL WAITING ON YOU TO
DELIVER THE GLENN YOUNGKIN VEST
TO MY DESK.
WE'LL BE LOOKING FOR IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> I L